in afghanistan the now ruling radical
islamist taliban are expected to form a
new government
as early as today while the group is
under international scrutiny over its
vow to rule with greater tolerance
there's also
questions of funding how are the taliban
going how are they going to financially
support themselves and the country that
until now has largely been kept afloat
by foreign aid here's what we know so
far
where does the taliban's money come from
the united nations says most of it comes
from criminal activities the drug trade
extortion human trafficking prostitution
as well as the mining of resources and
tax revenue from areas the terror group
controls
the u.n security council estimates that
in 2020 the taliban earned 460 million
u.s dollars in the opium trade alone
that would account for a major part of
their total revenue estimated between
300 million and 1.6 billion dollars
but other revenue streams have become
more important in recent years the
taliban take a 10 percent cut from
legally grown farm produce
as well as profits from businesses and
stores
they also charge tolls at road
checkpoints often resorting to violence
another key source of revenue is
donations from countries such as
pakistan saudi arabia qatar as well as
private donors and foundations
afghanistan is estimated to hold natural
resources worth more than a trillion
dollars including lithium copper
aluminum gold and rare earths
china russia and turkey are interested
in mining rights but want to see a more
stable political environment economists
doubt the taliban can build up a solid
economy afghanistan has long depended on
financial assistance in 2020 foreign aid
accounted for 43 of the country's gdp
many countries including germany said
they will halt further payments
complicating the situation is the
taliban's lack of access to
afghanistan's reserves of around 9.5
billion dollars in the u.s the money is
currently frozen
for more let's bring in journalist and
author emerald faroes who has been
reporting extensively on afghanistan
welcome to dw as many experts are
projecting a sharp downturn for the
afghan economy which is the most
important revenue stream for the taliban
right now
well the thing is what we have with the
taliban the main problem is that they
are still getting used
of being an insurgent group and now they
have to act like a state because they're
governing
and all the streams they had all the
ones that you mentioned uh a few a few
seconds ago they will not be enough to
uh
held afghanistan stable and for that
reason uh they need to be more
professional and
they i think they're very well aware
that afghanistan still
will be dependent of foreign aid and for
that reason they have to find
a proper way to handle it but
unfortunately it seems that they will
not have all the expertise because they
just
declared that the new head of the
central bank is a guy of course one of
their group but he seems to be more of a
religious cleric than an
economic expert and for that reason they
have to
find other experts amongst afghans who
are not amongst the taliban of course
so of course knowledge of monetary
policy is always helpful how big a role
are donations from countries like
pakistan or
saudi arabia playing and what do those
countries intend by financially
supporting the taliban
yeah the thing is
we don't know exactly how about how many
millions we are talking here i think
that a lot of them are private donors
and of course the taliban themselves
is also their leadership parts of them
they become
businessmen during the last two decades
for example the former head of the
taliban who was killed
mansoor he was also a businessman and a
lot of the taliban leaders in qatar also
somehow became businessmen but all of
this will not be enough because as i
said they used to be an insurgent group
and the states or private donors that
funded them funded them as an insurgent
group but now they have to lead the
afghan state so
all of that all the money they got in
the past will not be enough to feed a
country of 30 million people
foreign governments are saying they will
be talking to the taliban as they are in
control of afghanistan now will foreign
companies and investors as well
i think they will i think also foreign
governments will
and in westers of course because it's
about business and i think that after 20
years of war they came to the conclusion
that the taliban are part of
the political reality of afghanistan and
that they are now
the ones who are in power i think it
would be very disastrous if
foreign countries start to sanction
afghanistan because of the
new taliban regime because obviously the
total majority of the people would
suffer and it would be wrong to suffer
afghans in a collective
journalist amron ferros thank you for
your thoughts
staying in afghanistan western union the
world's largest money transfer service
was set to resume wires to the country
after getting a green light from the us
treasury that's good news for afghans
with family overseas others are finding
cash difficult to come by and that could
be just one of the problems for the
taliban
the lines outside the banks are long and
too often there's no money at the end of
them
but
signs of change
kabul's largest currency exchange market
resumes operations next saturday after
intense haggling with the central bank
the taliban have ordered private banks
to be reopened too although limits on
withdrawals and other restrictions are
hampering the process
[Music]
we shared all the problems we had with
the private banks and the suggestions we
had with the head of the central bank of
afghanistan
the problems we had say with the bank
accounts
and we told them that 60 to 70 percent
of the money changers money should be
processed through private banks
if we can open the market we could solve
the problems
sharmila hashimi an afghan living in
berlin is trying to send money home to
her family in kabul she describes a grim
situation
on the thousands of people outside of
the bank were like shouting or my money
i need my money
and it was very very clear if they
opened the door if any of this colleague
come out for sure all these thousand
people go to him on to kill them because
they think these people don't want to
take give our money or we need an animal
that was a very bad day
even before the taliban's power grab
afghanistan's economy struggled
but the rise of the taliban has been a
shock
40 percent of the economy was reliant on
foreign donors but overseas aid has
stopped
security is deteriorating and the
country is facing its worst drought in
decades
the price of flour oil and rice as well
as fuel has been rising every day
western union the world's largest money
transfer firm can start making wire
transfers of money from overseas again
overseas remittances make up four
percent of the afghan gdp
the taliban say they will rely primarily
on financing from china to rebuild the
economy
beijing seems willing to back the
taliban but even china is unlikely to
invest too heavily until it sees proof
of stability